[Applause]
welcome to hot takes brought to you by
rain body fuel shout out to rain on this
week's hot take my boy Donald cowboy
Cerrone was here at thick boy Studios
and he alluded to that Jake Paul's
legitimate fighter he compared to Conor
McGregor the great Conor McGregor and
says he's a big money fight and that he
would love to fight him
then Jake Paul responded on the Schmo
Show and said hold up
is Donald Cerrone out of his UFC
contract and the schmoe said he is he
went interesting but then he said uh I'm
kind of tired of beating up these old
dudes
now on the surface it sounds like Jake
Paul's dismissing the idea and wants to
fight a legit boxer because he's getting
that pressure from the MMA fan base in
the boxing fan base which
he's never going to please that crowd
unless he fights like a Javonte Davis or
Canelo which is never going to happen so
get off your high horse
but I actually think this is Jake Paul
playing the game nobody plays this
boxing AKA fight game Better Than Jake
Paul I think he's testing the waters
here because Cowboy could be a
formidable opponent to say the least and
listen is Donald Cerrone older yeah he's
not a young Huckleberry he's not a young
buck but he's eight years younger than
Ash and Silva who was Jake Paul's last
fight and it was also Jake Paul's
toughest fight he's eight years younger
he's also a different Donald Cerrone
and Jake Paul I'm sure you're aware of
this if you haven't seen donceroni
lately this is not the cowboy that
you've seen been who's been fighting the
occur in the past few years this is a
completely different Donald Cerrone this
is Hollywood Donald Cerrone this is Jack
to the gills Donald Cerrone I don't know
if you saw him on my uh cow basses fight
companion
I've known Cowboy for 18 years I've
never seen him in better shape now that
usadas not forcing up pee in cups all
the time he can do whatever he wants
that's a problem for anybody who fights
down cerronex the dude was already a
Workhorse when it came to conditioning
and practice and now he goes dude I
can't stop on this stuff acai a legal
acai he can't stop he's never felt
stronger
so if you think you're just gonna get
the normal Donald ceroni you are sadly
mistaken Mr Paul this is completely
different animal you're also dealing
with a cowboy who's known for taking
short notice fights no camps just
signing up that's why we love him he's
beloved by the UFC fan base because he
would fight anyone anytime anywhere that
wasn't always the best for his career
but that's why we love him so it's a
double-edged sword there but remember a
lot of those fights he wasn't properly
trained was cutting weight like crazy
but if you fight Donald Cerrone you got
to realize you're not getting that Don
Cerrone you're getting a much
well-rested Donald Cerrone that's just
focusing on boxing and the dude can box
and who else are you gonna fight let's
go through it Jakey who else are you
gonna fight Mike Perry's out there be a
great fight fun fight bigger name the
cowboy probably not Nate Diaz I haven't
heard anything on that
figure like February you get done by now
I haven't heard anything on that that's
a big fight bigger than Donald there's
an argument there Conor McGregor's under
UFC contract that ain't happening forget
about it that ship has sailed for now it
will happen eventually but not any time
this year that ain't happening so
Connor's out Nate's out Mike Perry's a
viable option I love Mike that'd be a
fun fight but his he's not gonna bring
in the same eyeballs that my boy Don
Cerrone is they got Tommy Fury you tried
it twice he's also not a legitimate box
it makes no sense it might be a feather
in your cap and might check the box
because he has last name Fury but in the
boxing World nobody gives that guy any
credit so you're not doing yourself any
favors there besides adding more money
to your bank account probably another
sweet knockout but if you actually want
to test you want to test yourself to one
of the best ever do it in the UFC a
first ballot Hall of Famer who's not
over the hill and who is ready to go
Thomas Rhone is your huckleberry I just
spoke to the man close friend of mine I
said yo Cowboy you see this stuff with
Jake Paul
he goes I sure did he goes if he's
willing to ongo drug testing tell him to
send me the damn contract I'm ready to
go
your move Jakey
it's the biggest
fight possible for you right now there's
no Conor there's no Nate there's no
Tommy Fury but there's Donald Cerrone
and a brand new version of Don Cerrone
take my money boys I hope the fight
happens I hope you hear this Jake I know
you well I hope the contract comes to
fruition I hope you boys make more money
than God and you both sail off into the
sunset with just bags of cash it'd be a
great fight it'd be a tough fight for
both of you make it happen your move
Jakey